so I asked you all here for a reason you
need a lift
will not be returning to engineering
oh God just don't tell me it's a food
truck I got through to the next round
the Mission Mart Space Program
I'm going to Mars
Mars
the planet
yep it's a one-way Journey so I wanted
to tell you all as soon as I knew for
sure I'm sorry are we joking
I'm
I'm going to Mars
liquid mass
NASA oh NASA's still like 20 years out
we're gonna be going intent I'm gonna
start training soon in isolation so I
wanted to make sure that we all spend
some time together before that happens
you really believe this film crew the
what
if they want to interview me for the
news they actually want to talk to you
guys too other people know about this hi
uh come in come on
Lisa Kessler NBC local news 5. where can
we set up uh just over there in the
background hi I'm Lisa Kessler hi so
cute okay great
this is really dark
um
um oh I gotta get an Instagram shot here
can you let this happen dad he's an
adult Liz
lost it
Liz after the accident he spent months
just lying in his room and now he gets
up early goes outside so does it really
matter why of course it matters well how
do you know this isn't real this is a
private company they have memes means to
get to Mars do you have any idea what
that would cost what kind of Technology
they would need well no but he does and
he's excited and he's happy Dad I'm
gonna get back to work
you need to let Alex do this why because
whatever gets him out of bed in the
morning we will support